يعني هذه كما قلنا بدايه التغيير في
اللغه التي كان يستخدمها حزب الله
واعتقد يعني هم يصرحون طبعا
بانهم تابعون
للولي الفقيه في ايران ولارشاداته
والتوجيهاته
ويتلقون منه الاوامر ولذلك عندما ينجح مثل
هذا الاتفاق اعتقد بان يعني بان حزب الله
سيغير سياسته
وسيطيع
القياده الايرانيه في مشروع الاندماج في
مشروع الدوله
وعند اذن تتغير الامور
تعتقد ان حزب الله مستقبلا سيندمج سيتنازل
في الدخول مع نظام سياسي وطني في لبنان
سيد علي
طبعا اعتقد لانه هو اذا يعني المؤشرات على
ذلك هل تلمس اي مؤشرات اليوم في على القلب
في بدايه هذه الايام وان كان الحكم مبكرا
على هذا الامر
يعني ما اسمعه طبعا من
من
يعني مؤيدي حزب الله ومن قيادات حزب الله
نسمع هناك ثناء ومديحا لهذا الاتفاق وهذا
انكشف عن شيء انهم يكشف عن انهم يمكن ان
يتغيروا وان
يطبق يعني ما ينتج عن هذا الاتفاق من
سياسات في المنطقه وفي لبنان بالخصوص طبعا